what do you presume will occur on Friday
when the truce is over I think everybody
is hoping that talks will start in Egypt
over the next 72 hours and and then
there'll be no further fighting and the
talks will continue on a more permanent
kind of agreement that would hold for a
while when we say that the Israeli army
and the IDF have left Gaza where do they
go do they go just over the border and
they're sitting there or did they go
home as far as I understand on the
border izle does not give a lot of
details deployment what they did say
just a few hours Silvo that they have no
more troops in gaza they did not say
specifically where they were but from
what I've understood of what people said
over the past couple of days they intend
to stay on the border until it's clear
the ceasefire will hold when the fragile
truce that has been part of a life in
Jerusalem was shattered yesterday when
they were two incidents involving a
couple of individuals who lost their
lives can you tell us what it's like in
Jerusalem today Jerusalem is a city used
to violence so people really just move
on these were told or portrayed to the
public as isolated incidents and not
something that the police think will
become a bigger kind of empty fada
uprising violence in Jerusalem so today
things are back to normal